te invito a que le hagas una pausa a
este vídeo y pienses para que valores de
x está definida esta función
o en otras palabras cuál es el dominio
de esta función y después de eso intenta
graficar la por tu propia cuenta en
algún pedazo de papel que tengas a la
mano o algo por el estilo y piensa
además si tiene acento estás verticales
y en dónde las tiene
así que suponiendo que ya hiciste todas
estas ideas vamos a tratar de hacerlo
entonces primero veamos dónde está
definida y lo que sabemos del logaritmo
natural es que su donde está definida es
en valores positivos estos son mayores
que 0 así que esto de aquí lo que está
dentro de bueno lo que estamos evaluando
en el logaritmo esto debe ser positivo
positivo y debe ser estrictamente
positivo es decir esto no puede ser cero
porque no sabemos o al menos no no no se
ha definido no está definido de hecho
cuál es el logaritmo natural de cero así
que x menos 3 debe ser estrictamente
mayor que 0 muy bien entonces como como
debe ser estrictamente mayor que 0
porque no se ha definido en cero
entonces si sumamos tres de ambos lados
tenemos que x tiene que ser mayor que 3
así que la función está definida
x mayor que 3 muy bien entonces vamos a
tratar de hacer la gráfica eso era el
siguiente paso tratar de hacer la
gráfica ahí tienen ustedes el eje i
digamos aquí está el eje x
x
ahí está el eje y muy bien entonces
vamos a ponerle algunos puntos digamos
este es el 1 el 2 el 3
digamos ahí en el 4 el 5 en fin
ahora una forma de aproximarnos a cómo
graficar esto es por ejemplo pensar para
qué valores de x se tiene que el
logaritmo natural de x menos 3 es igual
a 0
esto nos daría la intersección con el
eje x verdad porque ya sería 0 entonces
estamos sobre el eje x y una forma
también de resolverlo es bueno qué tal
si estos son exponentes de e
es decir si tuviéramos que y es que al a
logaritmo natural de x menos 3 sería
igual a elevado a la 0 pero he elevado a
logaritmo natural de x menos tres es
simplemente x 3 porque son funciones
inversas verdad el logaritmo natural
pregunta
a qué exponente hay que elevar para que
nos dé x 3 y si elevamos a ese exponente
a ese número en realidad solo nos da x 3
verdad pues sí entonces del lado derecho
tendremos a la 0 y elevar y al hacer de
hecho elevar cualquier número número a
la 0 es una verdad excepto cuando
elevamos 0 a la 0 que eso no está bien
definido así que bueno de todos modos no
es cero así que aquí tenemos esta nueva
relación que x menos 3 es igual a 1 por
lo tanto si sumamos 3 de ambos lados
tenemos x igual a 13 que es 4 así que en
4 nos vamos aquí en 4 estamos
intersectando al eje x en el punto 4,0
hay un punto de la gráfica por otro lado
sabemos que esto está definido para
valores mayores estrictamente que 3 así
que digamos que esta línea divisoria
está esta línea divide
donde está definida la función muy bien
así que ya vamos construyendo un poco
más y ahora vamos a ver qué pasa si nos
vamos aproximando a tres que es justo en
donde está nuestro digamos nuestro
nuestro cambio de comportamiento es
verdad antes de tres no está definida y
después de tres si vamos a ver qué pasa
si nos aproximamos a tres así que vamos
a hacerlo box que fue a línea vamos a
hacerlo a través de una tablita y vamos
a ir aproximando valores entonces
sabemos que para cuatro la función vale
cero vamos a ver qué pasa en 3.1
quizás en 3.01 3.001 vamos a ver qué
pasa entonces si tenemos tres puntos 0 1
y le restamos 3 a 900 y es 3.1 primero
3.1
otra vez 3.1 y le restamos 3 esto nos da
0.1 y sacamos logaritmo natural y nos da
menos 2.3 así que una aproximación es
menos 2.3 que pasas y ahora tenemos 3
puntos 0 1 menos 3 eso nos da 0.01 y
después sacamos logaritmo natural y nos
da menos cuatro menos 4.6 todo esto esta
redondeado verdad tenemos ahora 3.001
menos 3 y nos da 0.001 y al aplicarle
logaritmo natural nos da menos 6.9 menos
6.9 entonces esto se va haciendo cada
vez más y más negativo no se pensemos en
algún caso ya muy muy muy dramático 1 2
3 4 5 6 ceros con 1 - 3
nos da esto y si aplicamos logaritmo
natural nos da menos 16 punto más o
menos 12 entonces si te das cuenta esta
función se va haciendo cada vez más y
más y más negativa a medida que nos
aproximamos a 3 así que esto más o menos
tiene esta cara
más o menos hace algo así
el detalle es que cada vez que nos
aproximamos más y más a tres
esto va haciéndose más y más y más
negativo hasta atender a menos infinito
mientras que del otro lado pues va
creciendo muy bien entonces ahí está la
gráfica de hecho la pregunta era si
tenía una cinta está vertical y si tiene
una cinta está vertical tiene una cinta
sin tota vertical
x igual a 3 x 3
así que absolutamente es cierto que
tenemos una cinta vertical porque
cerquita del 3 no está acotada nuestra
función de hecho se va a menos infinito